hey 42 here Charles lechmere was walking
to work in the London District of White
Chapel at 3 40 am on the 31st of August
1888 when he stumbled across the body of
a woman lying on the pavement this being
London's notorious East End lechmere
assumed she was passed out drunk but
before he had a chance to investigate
further a second figure followed from
the [ __ ] his name was Robert Paul and
between then they debated what to do
next
Paul wanted to prop the young lady up to
Aid her recovery but Charles fought it
better to leave her be unable to agree
on the best course of action they went
looking for help
whilst they were gone a local Bobby on
his beat by the name of PC John Neal
arrived on the scene he was carrying a
lantern and it illuminated something
that neither Charles lechmere nor Robert
Paul had noticed in the dim Morning
Light a pool of dark liquid slowly
spreading from beneath the woman's neck
she wasn't passed out drunk
she was dead
nobody knew it at the time but the most
infamous serial killer in history had
just claimed his first Victor
[Music]
over the following 70 days London was
gripped by fear as the mysterious
murderer who came to be known as Jack
the Ripper claimed four more lives sure
the world had already seen serial
killers but Jack wanted much more than
any that had come before because he
mutilated his victim's body with
shocking brutality but just when it
seemed as though these killings would
never end only two months on the Ripper
was gone whoever or whatever had been
stalking the Streets of London just
disappeared
now I love food and I wish I could sit
down every morning for a lengthy
breakfast but by 9am I'm usually
knee-deep in emails and my mind is
totally consumed by whatever project I'm
currently working on for the channel
before I know it it's 11 A.M and I'm so
hungry I just grab any unhealthy snack
lying around well that bad habit is no
more since I've been using huel for me
huel is a nutritionally complete
breakfast that I can make in literally
30 seconds it fills me up it has
everything a human needs to function and
most importantly it doesn't interrupt my
workflow to make a heel Shake I simply
add 500 mL of water to my heel shaker
bottle add two scoops of fuel powder and
well give it a good shake my favorite is
this black edition cookies and cream it
tastes so rich and chocolaty with a hint
of cookies and cream and it's just so
good but fuel contains no tricks it's
not a fat diet it's just a no fuss way
to add some plant-based food into your
life I especially like to start my day
on a good amount of protein because
protein is so essential to pretty much
every function of the human body and
each serving of fuel contains a massive
40 grams of protein and loads of fiber
as well oh and it's got less than five
percent sugar it's also really
affordable so click the link in the
description to try heal today and if you
use my special link you'll be supporting
the channel and you'll also get a free
heel shaker bottle so don't miss out and
thanks to huel for sponsoring this video
the last Ripper victim was buried more
than 130 years ago but interest in this
most gory of Unsolved Mysteries has
never waned endless professionals and
amateur sleuths alike have poured
millions of hours into piecing this
puzzle together but even today questions
remain
how did the killer commit his crimes on
the busy Streets of London without ever
being caught why were so many people
murdered in such a short space of time
and why so far as we know that the
Ripper never take another life after his
Killing Spree ended in November 1888
and of course then there's the most
important question of all
who was Jack the Ripper
I don't claim to have a definitive
answer to that last question but if you
stick around to the end I have a very
very strong candidate to tell you about
one who isn't usually even mentioned
when people talk about Jack the Ripper
but first things first it's probably
worth briefly recapping the case for
those of you who aren't up to date on
your 130 year old true crime stories
that first victim the one found by
Charles lechmere and Robert Paul was
identified as Marianne Nichols a
subsequent post-mortem revealed the true
extent of her injuries most of which had
been hidden beneath her clothes when her
body was found her neck had been severed
by two cuts so deep the knife had
scraped her vertebrae and she'd been
stabbed multiple times in the stomach
and groin it was a brutal assault but
Jack the Ripper was just getting started
[Music]
just over a week later the body of Annie
Chapman was found on Hanbury Street near
spettlefield's Market in the early hours
of the morning just like Mary Annie's
throat had been severed by two deep Cuts
but with the second killing the
mutilations were far more severe Mary's
torso had been badly slashed but Annie
Chapman had practically been dissected
the killer had removed several of her
internal organs arranging them around
the body and her uterus and parts of her
bladder and vagina had been taken from
the scene entirely
in the space it's just nine days two
innocent women had been murdered in
horrific fashion
the people of London were terrified but
they were all so fascinated Jack the
Ripper was the first serial killer to
hit the global headlines he was
sensationalized by newspapers all around
the world
from the outset people were enthralled
but as the days went by interest in the
Ripper shot Sky High when all of a
sudden this Specter stalking the Streets
of London started writing letters there
were hundreds of them in total some sent
to the media obvious to the police
but whilst the vast majority are today
thought to have been hoaxes because what
could be funnier than pretending to be a
psychopathic serial killer there is one
single slip of paper some experts
believed was scribbled by the real
Ripper
the so-called from Hell letter
if you're wondering what it was about
this particular missive that suggests it
was genuine I can tell you that it has
nothing to do with handwriting analysis
or the origin of the postmark no it was
much simpler than that the letter was
delivered alongside half a human kidney
and as we're about to find out the
police had a pretty good idea of where
it might have come from
12 Days After Annie Chapman met her
maker the next two Ripper victims were
killed within an hour of each other
Elizabeth stride was first but her
murder was a little unusual like before
her throat had been cut but the rest of
her body was left untouched most
ripperologists yep that's a thing
believe the killer was interrupted
before he got a chance to get to work
that would explain why he killed again
so fast before the hour had passed and
Catherine eddos whose body was found
just 45 minutes aft received the full
Ripper routine so to speak like Annie
Chapman Edo's body had been horrifically
mutilated with her abdomen sliced open
and several of her internal organs
arranged around the body but this time
the rip had also taken the time to
disfigure the victim's face
once again some organs were missing from
the scene entirely including a whole
kidney
you're wondering what happened to the
half not delivered with the letter the
author claimed to have eaten it
yeah
it's hard to imagine a more gruesome
murder but as it turns out
the people of London didn't have to
because Jack the Ripper saved his most
devastating work until last and The
Unlucky recipient was Mary Jane Kelly
found on the morning of Friday the 9th
of September
unlike every other rapper victim she was
murdered indoors in the single bedroom
she rented in a building off Dorset
Street
according to an FBI criminal profile
written in the 1980s the additional
privacy gave the Ripper the time to
truly indulge his Twisted fantasies and
indulge them he most certainly did it's
estimated he spent around two hours with
the body inflicting mutilations that are
quite simply beyond words when he was
finished Mary Jane's own mother wouldn't
have recognized her
if you have an incredibly strong stomach
pictures do exist if the crime scene but
that information comes with a very
serious warning the images are some of
the most disturbing ever captured on
film and once seen
they can never be unseen by this point
in our story The London Police Force are
in the midst of the biggest Manhunt in
recent memory several thousand londoners
were interviewed around 300 suspects
were actively investigated and more than
80 people were brought in for
questioning but of course nobody was
ever convicted and the crimes remain
quite possibly the most famous Cold Case
in the world
as many as 500 people have been accused
of being jacked the Ripper over the
years some of these suggestions are as
you would expect that's insane some
ripperologists mostly the unhinged ones
believe Prince Albert grandson of Queen
Victoria and second in line to the
throne was Jack the Ripper according to
the theory he had an illegitimate child
with a White Chapel prostitute and
understandably embarrassed by this
decidedly on princely Behavior proceeded
to eliminate everyone who knew his Dirty
Little Secret another shall we say left
field theory is that Alice in Wonderland
author Lewis Carroll was the killer the
reasoning behind this one is actually
quite compelling at first glance author
Richard Wallace found that if you
rearrange the letters in certain
sections of Carol's poems they spelled
out a detailed confession of his guilt
that's absolutely true by the way there
really is a hidden confession and in
Lewis Carroll's poems but before you go
and burn your copy of Alice Through the
Looking Glass in protest turns out that
if you take a long enough passage of
text from literally any book in history
you can scramble the letters to say
anything you like a fact that was proven
quite spectacularly when critics of
Wallace's work rearranged the first few
lines of his own book to spell out a
confession that he'd framed O.J Simpson
and secretly written Shakespeare's
sonnets
anyway aside from the utter lack of
evidence the likes of Prince Albert and
Lewis Carroll simply don't fit the
Killer's profile one of the most
striking things about the Ripper murders
is just how tightly grouped they were
all five victims were killed within a
mile of each other
that suggests a real Ripper lived
somewhere nearby
a deduction doubly backed by the fact he
knew the streets of Whitechapel like the
back of his blood-soaked hand
the Ripper is often portrayed in books
and films as a Suave Aristocrat type
that preys on the poor but it's much
more likely that he was an ordinary
Working Man from Whitechapel
his choice of victim is also interesting
you probably noticed that all five were
ladies who were killed at night but they
were also ladies of the night
prostitutes
maybe prostitutes made for an easy
target or perhaps the Ripper had a tin
for them specifically
apply this General profile to the most
common Ripper suspects
few interesting candidates begin to
stand out
now unless you're a real ripperologist
you probably aren't aware that the
serial killer called Jack the Ripper was
once known by a different name leather
apron
after the murder of Marianne Nichols
police spoke to many of her friends and
acquaintances several of whom were
fellow prostitutes
during those interviews one phrase kept
cropping up over and over again
leather apron
that turned out to be a nickname of
sorts one given by The Prostitute of
Whitechapel to a mysterious man many of
them had been threatened by in the past
he was said to wear a distinctive
leather apron and carry a long sharp
knife in his belt
and whilst nobody seemed to know his
real name white Chapel's prostitutes
were clearly absolutely terrified of him
soon enough the police identified this
prostitute boverer as local boot maker
John Pisa he was called in for
questioning and it soon transpired he'd
been responsible for a number of minor
assaults on prostitutes he also had a
prior conviction for stabbing someone
it's difficult to imagine a more perfect
Ripper candidate Pisa was local he had a
thing for prostitutes and he'd already
shown himself to be a little bit stabby
unfortunately there is one small flaw
that we simply can't ignore he had a
cast iron Alibi for not one but two of
the murders another name commonly tossed
around is that of James maybrick A
prominent Liverpool cotton Merchant who
was himself murdered by his wife soon
after the last Ripper victim met the
knife
that's a pretty good start one of the
oddest things about the entire case is
the abrupt end to the murders so any
suspects that either died got locked up
or moved away automatically gets a bonus
point
so did Mrs Maverick kill her husband
after finding out who he really was
perhaps but the key piece of evidence
that points to me because the Killer is
actually a diary one that didn't surface
until more than a hundred years after
his death published in 1992 it was found
by a scrap metal dealer from Liverpool
called Michael Barrett who claimed to
have been given it by a friend
the diary detailed all five Ripper
murders as well as two of us the police
had never even connected with the case
and whilst no name was included it
didn't take long to figure out who the
diary belonged to James maybrick
of course when a hundred-year-old diary
randomly turns up conveniently
confirming the identity of the most
famous felon of all time there are
always going to be people who call
[ __ ] but Barrett was more than happy
to submit the diary for testing and
initial analysis was positive it was
written in a genuine Victorian notebook
in genuine Victorian Inc it also
contained a wealth of information that
seemed to be consistent with maybrick's
life
either the diary was genuine or it was
one hell of an impressive hoax
but just when it looked like this
century-long case could finally be
closed Michael Barrett was exposed by
himself
he admitted to having forged a diary
with his wife
despite the confessions some
ripperologists still believe maybrick
was Jack the Ripper for one thing it
isn't entirely clear whether Barrett's
confession of forgery was actually real
he later retracted it then retracted the
retraction then retracted the retraction
of the retraction then
you get the idea
still if the diary was the only evidence
in maybrick's favor it would be easy to
dismiss him as a suspect because why
would Barrett admit to forging something
that was genuinely genuine but in 1993 a
Victorian pocket watch was discovered
with an engraving on the inside cover
containing Maverick's name the initials
of the Ripper's five victims and the
words I am Jack now I know what you're
thinking that was obviously forgery too
but analysis of the watch by two experts
concluded not only that it dated back to
the right time period but that the
Engravings on the inside were several
decades old at least perhaps even older
bearing in mind that may brick wasn't
even suggested as a suspect until the
discovery of the Diary in 1992 and we're
left with a bit of an enigma here
could he have been the killer let me
know what you think in the comments
section
back in 2019 newspapers all around the
world proudly proclaimed that the
infamous killer known as Jack the Ripper
had finally been caught by that most
unairing of detectives modern forensic
science
the stories were triggered by an
academic paper that claims to have
linked DNA found on a shawl belonging to
Catherine eddos to a living relative of
one Aaron kasminsky
paranoid schizophrenic who lived and
worked in White Chapel at the time of
the murders kazminsky is thought to have
been one of the original Ripper suspects
back in the 1880s and interestingly he
was admitted to a mental hospital in
1891 not long after The Killing Spree
came to an end
kazminsky is widely regarded as one of
the most likely Ripper candidates but
the deeper you dig into his story The
more holes you find
it turns out that the forensic evidence
on which his entire case stands was
based on mitochondrial DNA something
that can be shared by thousands of
different people not only that but
nobody seems to be 100 certain that the
shore definitely belonged to caffron
Edo's in the first place
okay so you're probably starting to see
a pattern here for every plausible
candidate there's an equally plausible
explanation as to why they probably
weren't Jack the Ripper the truth is the
same can be said for almost every Ripper
suspect you care to mention
but
not quite all of them and I've saved a
man I believe to be the best candidate
till last
Jack the Ripper was famous for his
elusiveness so it only seemed right that
my personal favorite was hiding in plain
sight for more than a century before
anyone even suspected him
unlike many of the more famous Ripper
suspects this man wasn't a prince a
famous author of a wealthy Aristocrat he
was just about as normal a man as you
could ever imagine
so utterly inconspicuous that he's
already appeared in this video and
there's every chance you never gave him
a Second Glance any guesses
let's go back to the Ripper's first
victim for a second Marianne Nichols did
you notice anything strange about her
murder
unlike most victims her body was left
relatively unmolested at least by Jack
the Ripper standards and the killer took
the time to cover up her injuries
beneath her clothes whilst every other
victim was left quite deliberately on
display
it's a small detail but it may well have
huge implications traditionally
ripperologists have assumed Mary's
murder was slightly less brutal than the
others because Jack was still learning
his trade and that's certainly a
possibility but what if the mutilations
were less severe because the killer
never got the chance to finish them
I started this video by telling you that
Charles lechmere stumbled across Mary's
body on his way to work
that's exactly what was recorded in the
police report
but if we imagine the scene from Robert
Paul's perspective things look a little
bit different I mean just think about it
Paul basically arrived to find Charles
lechmere standing over the body of a
murdered woman
could he have been the Ripper all along
if he was when he heard Robert Paul
approaching he had a split second
decision to make either make a run for
it or stay put and pretend to have just
found the body I didn't make up that
little detail about lesmere being
reluctant to move the body by the way
that was in the police report too
[Music]
if he was the killer he would have known
that moving Mary would have made it
abundantly clear that she'd been
murdered it also seems that lechmere
kept a deliberately low profile in the
days after the murder he didn't come
forward to give evidence at the inquest
until Robert Paul mentioned him to the
press and even then he ended up giving
evidence under a different name Charles
cross
that was the family name of one of his
two stepfathers who died years earlier
and it's possible he just used it
routinely but it's also possible he was
trying to cover his tracks
unfortunately we know very little about
lechmere's life he was never considered
a suspect by the police at the time so
he wasn't investigated and as an
ordinary working-class man living in
White Chapel few records of his life
have survived pretty much all we do know
is his address 22 doveton Street and his
occupation
he was a meat car driver for a local
company called pickford's
it isn't much to go on but even these
scant details are intriguing being a
meat car driver lechmere would have
commonly handled animal carcasses which
is a pretty good reason for wandering
around with blood on your clothes
not only that but if you map his likely
route to work based on his home address
and the address of his employer it's
clear he would have passed conveniently
close to the locations of at least three
White Chapel murders in the early hours
of the morning exactly when all the
Ripper victims were found
there's also the irrefutable fact that
he looks exactly like old man Marley
from Home Alone
and as far as I'm concerned that's
reason enough to be suspicious
if someone had fought to point the
finger at lechmere 130 years ago perhaps
this case would have been closed and we
wouldn't be talking about the mysterious
Jack the Ripper today but they didn't
and with so much water having passed
under the proverbial Bridge since then
we simply don't have enough evidence to
make firm conclusions most of the people
who lived through the Ripper murders
have been dead for well over a hundred
years at this point and the bulk of the
police files around the case were
destroyed in the Blitz
as frustrating as that is these huge
evidential blind spots are a big part of
what makes the story of Jack the Ripper
such a compelling one even today
lechmere May well have been the killer
but we can't rule out the possibility
that he was just some random guy he was
just unlucky enough to find a dead body
on his walk to work somebody had to
after all and a man who lived and worked
in White Chapel was more likely to do so
than most
any one of the people looking out at you
now might have been Jack the Ripper or
perhaps we've never even been close to
correctly identifying the real killer
and his name has already been lost to
history whatever the truth these were
some of the most brutal and disturbing
crimes ever committed and yet whoever
carried them out got away scot-free
just think about that for a second
whoever Jack the Ripper was
he'll have had friends colleagues lovers
thousands of people must have spent time
with the most notorious serial killer in
history
without ever even realizing it and if
that doesn't creep you out
nothing will
thanks for watching